foreign
City hey Adam what's up
hi Dave hi Ken thank you so much for
having me on the show sure what's up
um I have a question I'm trying to get a
few thoughts organized so I have a house
that is rented in a different state with
a mortgage of 216
000 currently and then I have my primary
residence in Salt Lake City which I
bought the last year and I'm trying to
decide whether I should keep both or
sell the rented uh property and then uh
the other part of the question I'm
trying to decide is I don't want to stay
in the primary residence for longer than
say two or three years because I would
like to ultimately buy a land and build
a house so I'm just trying to figure out
what would be the best option and then
start thinking about how to get there in
the next few years that's fun what do
you make
one hundred and three thousand good for
you girls and how old are you
of 32. good for you well done okay
the way we answer questions around here
Adam is based on uh what I know
uh what would I do if I was trying to
build wealth the fastest right way
uh what would I do if I woke up in your
shoes and that's how I think about these
things when someone calls here on the
show okay
and I know a lot about real estate I've
been owning real estate and managing
real estate and dealing with landlord
and tenant issues most of my adult life
and so and I love real estate I hate
long-distance landlording
it's a it's a recipe for failure and so
and I love being debt free
all of those things lead me to sell the
rental house and pay off your personal
residence and then use the fact that you
make a lot of money and you have no
payments at that point to pile up cash
in a good investment to pay cash for uh
your upgrade on this build that you're
going to do and then pay cash for your
other rental properties if you want to
buy some more investment properties
later
but um that that advice is not popular
on tick tock
but I'm not running a Tick-Tock poll I'm
telling you based on a 40-year career of
helping people become millionaires what
I am pretty sure is that what I am very
sure is the best route for you to do the
same to become a millionaire and so I'm
not I'm not trying to run a popularity
contest here I'm just right there's a
difference
and so that's what we would tell you to
do well I think what we want to point
out here is is that what you just said
isn't going to happen overnight and
that's why these schemes and The Tick
Tock videos are so popular because it
promises something that just quite
frankly isn't true and has tremendous
risk to it the get rich quick idea
versus what you just told our friend
here Adam uh Adam is going to be very
wealthy yeah and he's also going to be
secure and sleep well at night
absolutely and he's obviously a sharp
young guy very sharp you know very cool
and he said at the end of his earning
potential either you got the feeling at
32 he's already making a hundred
thousand plus he's gonna be kicking it
yeah so you got a good you got a bright
future dude just be you know what I'm
telling you to do is the a way that has
very little to no risk and uh you're in
control of your life and you don't take
uh penalty steps backwards and get the
opportunity to start over
which by the way that's something worth
talking about for a minute and it works
in your career it works with your money
um
the thing that they're number one the
path to the gleaming mountain of success
is not a straight line
okay it's an ebb and flow there's a
little little uh Todd goes in Todd goes
out in the process and the gleaming
mountain of success is actually a pile
of your failures
that you're standing on the things
you've learned the hard way everyone I
know that is a household name brand name
in any part of the world whether it's a
pastor that everybody in America knows
who that Pastor is or got a huge
Ministry or whether it's an author
that's done multiple number one
bestsellers or whether it's a business
person or a sports person or whatever it
is every time I run music people the
people that are inordinately successful
are colossal failures yeah so the the
the gleaming mountain of success is a
pile of mistakes now what they don't do
what they do in John Maxwell our friend
talks about this he wrote a book years
ago called failing forward they don't
make fatal mistakes they don't make
mistakes that set you back so far
there's tiny mistakes for course
correction yeah
and
the thing that keeps people from
becoming wealthy is a they don't apply
themselves to a simple set of principles
and B by not applying themselves to that
simple set of principles they fall for
these get rich quick crap and they they
have these tremendous setbacks yeah you
know I went and bought 10 houses and put
them on Airbnb only to find out the and
leverage all of them to their eyeballs
only to find out that Airbnb is now
illegal in two of those cities and only
to find out that Airbnb in the rest of
the cities is completely flooded and I
can't keep them full and so I'm not
making any money and the guy on Tick
Tock lied to me yeah because he didn't
know what the flip he's talking about
that's right it means a lot to me or
maybe he did mean to lie to me I don't
know either way you lied to me I got bad
information and now you're getting ready
to get foreclosed on and you're going to
lose a portfolio of 10 properties and
you're gonna go bankrupt all because you
were stupid yeah and I've been stupid
like that I did that exact thing I had
to start completely over I'm so stupid
I've been a millionaire twice
right you know and so I I didn't just do
it once and it's a lot easier if you're
an atom situation just do it once that's
right here's what people Overlook Dave
about what you're saying greatness is a
process
you don't get to Greatness any of the
fields you mentioned without a process
you look at athletes you look at coaches
you look at Artists Craftsmen true
Craftsmen there is a process and what
they focus on is the little things the
fundamentals the process of trying the
process of failing to your point it's
not fatal they're going to learn from it
and what you learn when you have the
discipline to do the little things the
fundamentals to embrace the process
here's what happens you begin to hate
losing so very much that you will go the
extra mile to actually win and with this
Tick Tock generation and Instagram and
these get rich quick schemes it removes
the process the reason the baby steps
have worked for people
is because it's a process it doesn't
happen overnight but it does happen yeah
that's what successful people get they
embrace the process and I thought about
it but I was hanging out with this
comedian guy the other day that's got a
big Netflix special yeah and um did you
know you don't just go to a Netflix
special yeah no that you take all those
jokes and you go into small clubs and
test them yeah yeah and get brutalized
and then they get brutalized on the
exactly he said it's harsh but he said
before I get on there everything I know
everything I do on there I already know
works that's exactly I've had course
Corrections interesting this is the
Ramsey Show